- Hello and welcome to
the Yale2020 website.
I'm Kimberly Goff-Crews,
Secretary and Vice President
for University Life.
Although traditional
Commencement ceremonies
will have to wait until
we can meet in person,
we couldn't let this time
pass without celebrating
all members of the Yale
University Class of 2020.
As you explore this site,
you'll find content from the university
and from your schools.
We hope it will help you reflect
on your experience at Yale
and all you have accomplished.
We'll continue to add content
throughout the week and after May 18th,
and will keep the site
live for several months.
We'd really love to add
your photos and your videos.
You can contribute by using
the links on the website
or #Yale2020 on social media.
On Monday, May 18th,
beginning at 11 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time,
President Salovey's
address to the students,
and the official conferral of student
and honorary degrees will be live.
Chaplain Kugler will also share a blessing
and many schools will follow
with their own programming.
We hope you enjoy the site.
And on behalf of all of us at Yale,
warm congratulations to our graduates,
and their proud families and friends.